wer jetzt dachte ich ach so die konkret
aldi hat jetzt die ist jetzt angemeldet
hier in minecraft hero dingsbums
deswegen könnt ihr mich da jetzt auch
wählen müsste es einfach nur die
kommentare schreiben
oft steckt ccp hallo ich meine lieben
freunde und herzlich willkommen zurück
zu einer weiteren folge minecraft hexe
dorf dem minecraft heroes server heute
mal wieder allein und zwar habe ich ja
schon bei twitter schnell mit dieser
komischen wie woody sollte vielleicht
hat man den trainer machen damit ihr
auch etwas hört und zwar habe ich ja
schon letzte ich mache dabei einfach mal
immer irgendwelche sachen hier jetzt
denken sich die meisten natürlich wieder
was macht der mann starb es kaputt und
obergefreiter egal ich denke niemals
natürlich was macht der denn da wieder
bla bla bla bla bla co kg hat nichts
dazu und zwar habe ich mir so ein paar
gedanken gemacht über das haus und ich
habe auch schon bei über die
häuserdächer bau und ich hab auch schon
bei twitter gepostet auch kacke
das muss ich erstmal alles aufräumen ich
weiß noch gar nicht in diesem moment wie
die folge da gerettet wurde
weil ich das gerade halt wie gesagt im
voraus aufnehmen fakt ist bestimmt
richtig gerettet naja gut
und zwar habe ich mir habe ich bei
twitter gepostet
wie die häuser aussehen sollen wie die
häuser aus den werden wenn ich könig
würden sollen tun seiner ihr das wollt
die meisten wahrscheinlich nicht mehr
weil ich ja hier ein bisschen scheiße
gebaut hat mit simon
allerdings ihr könnt mir einfach mal
gucken wie häuser aussehen werden ich
werde versuchen in dieser folge schon
welche davon zu machen war zumal ist
darf ich mach ich mir noch mal so einen
stoff diamant und magic essenz so das
heißt magic habe ich hier in magic ist
schon irgendwie nur spiegel diamanten
habe ich aber schon mal 15 stockwerken
werden ein paar machen
vielleicht sollte ich noch ein bisschen
mehr sticks mitnehmen da wenig rad schon
dabei war dörner hier die bräute nicht
mehr
und zwar werden soll habe ich mir ein
bisschen gedanken gemacht und
singleplayer ich habe mir deine welt
erstellt habt ihr ein bisschen gespielt
und habe mir dann so gedacht okay so
sieht eigentlich ganz geil aus welche
die häuser so bauen werde auch der keine
verewigen legend schuldig welche häuser
zu bauen werde sagten wird bestimmt ganz
billig aussehen und dementsprechend
werde ich das in dieser folge in den
nächsten folgen mich mal daran setzen ob
ich das hinkriege dass sich die häuser
denn auch genau so wie ich sie vor
gebaut habe deswegen hab ich mir auch
dass wir nicht sogar wieder liegen blieb
dass ich ihr hört schon ich bin ein
bisschen krank dafür möchte mich erst
mal entschuldigen
deswegen habe ich mir eine kleine liste
aufgestellt mit den ganzen materialien
die ich brauche und die ich mir gleich
zusammen suchen werde erst mal
verzaubert hier kurz die zauberstäbe und
dann brauch ich das da hinten mal eben
ganz kurz zu und dann in der oder rom
ist es der picture wohin fließt das
wasser dann okay nah ist jetzt muss ich
nur noch abbauen eigentlich alles kaputt
ich brauche auf jeden fall am meisten
brauche ich + ich muss richtig richtig
richtig viel ruß wurde haben richtig
richtig viel brauche ich davon
nein ich habe diese komischen fehler
hier überall in der welt online woran
liegt das denn
schreibt mir das mal bitte wo liegt das
dass ich hier für komische fehler habe
london ist stört ein richtig beim
hausbau das richtig ärgerlich so egal
ich mache das jetzt erst mal ganz kurz
weg ich brauch richtig viel sprit und
richtig viel marble weil ich möchte den
ganzen flair der stadt zu behalten
dieses rad wird habe ich es mir nicht
aufgefallen passt gar nicht so gut zu
diesem sport clubs wie das wirkliches
blues wird dann auch dementsprechend
kommt ja auch alle weg was das ärgerlich
mit dieser kaffee hier wieder
ich hätte die folge wird wieder mega
gehärtet conny bei der grafik richtig
schlecht und besser du [ __ ]
das sind ja meist so die bekannte
beleidigung und eine zehn jahren kann
ich das nicht irgendwie weg machen es
mir scheiß egal ob die's bekommen oder
nicht
ach komm ich jetzt einmal ich lasse es
ob sie da jetzt einfach mal da als
zeichen der vollkommenheit unserer
damaligen königin isch kandidiere auch
hashtag ccp allemal in die kommentare
schreiben es nicht schreibt ist fixer
hashtag ccp von crafter partei richtig
einfallsreich cool aber hier ist es
nicht oder doch
auch man doch ist doch hier weiter vorne
back duo diaz hat hier geht's noch so
naja gut da habe ich da drin das ganz
gut weil damit mache ich mir erst mal so
ein paar von diesen plättchen com ist
das lab so viel brauche ich gar nicht so
ich versuche in dieser folge so weit zu
kommen wie möglich mit den ganzen
häusern dir ich kann aber nichts
versprechen ich weiß nicht welche die
einging machen ich mache jetzt einfach
hier regal läuft die mache so dann mache
ich das hier noch mal hier auf der
anderen seite oder warten ja ich glaube
ich kann das ja eh alles um ändern und
zwar sollen die häuser beide so ein
panoramafenster im obersten stock haben
dass man sich dazu gegenüber gucken kann
meine kisten kommen natürlich alle in
mein haus mein haus für das dasein
oder dass hier das da wird man dass da
hinten
und ja das da oben muss ich mich erst
mal alles abbauen weil das ist alles ein
bisschen überflüssig was deiner letzten
folge gebaute dass er letzten folge
wirklich einfach nur
arbeitsbeschaffungsmaßnahme das habe ich
nur gemacht damit ich hier überhaupt
irgendwas mache aber gedanken über den
wirklichen ob ich noch nicht gemacht wer
jetzt dachte ich ach so die konkreter
partei die hat jetzt die ist jetzt
angemeldet hier in minecraft dingsbums
deswegen könnt ihr mich da jetzt auch
wählen ihr müsst einfach nur die
kommentare schreiben
ganz oft hashtag ccp und dann bei der
königswall wird sich dann entscheiden ob
auch bombay das und kev dafür stimmen
dann bildet sich dann entscheiden
ich könnte jetzt mal eine leitsätze
vorsätzen was ich auf jeden fall
verändern würde ist das komplette stil
bild der stadt ich würde die stadt
komplett umkrempeln jetzt im bau sinne
warum sind hier eigentlich diese teile
die wollte ganz anders bauen also dass
die häuser werden echt mega geil hier
dürfen übrigens auch über aller leute
einzig bürger hier vier häuser hin hier
dürfen dann leute einziehen wenn kev
oder zombie oder so wenn die nicht
wissen was sie so bauen sollen können
die einfach auch hier einziehen erstmal
für die zwischenzeit dagegen hat den
könig natürlich nichts auszusetzen ich
zukünftiger könig wenn ich könig wäre
sollte
guck mal dass das blöde ist wieder sechs
minuten um ich kann hier wieder nix
machen also von crafter partei würde ich
dennoch alles wäre dann also auf jeden
fall werde ich die ganzen häuser unserer
stadt im stile der stadt lautern wollen
und zwar wird der stil der stadt spiel
der stadt blau wird so ähnlich aussehen
wie dieses ding da nur ich werd die
häuser mit viel viel mehr von diesen
plänen nicht mit redwood plankton mit
grußwort plank und damit wird in dieser
stadt hier glaub ich noch nichts gebaut
jedoch gar nichts mit den noch nix
footloose bad place gebaut also mit
diesem schlusswort verarbeitet das ist
ein bisschen dunkler als dieses redwood
unter redwood ich schon für statt rot
steht also in stadt roth vorkommt ist
das ja auch relativ billig dass wir das
dann nicht haben sondern wir dann das
blut haben was dann wohl eher für statt
braun stehen würde aber naja so da vorne
das haus jedoch eben danach gehen wir
mal eben bisschen spruce gut abfangen
auch in new york das ja auch schon ganze
zeit rum ja egal ich werde gleich
wahrscheinlich noch eine folge alleine
aufnehmen weil ich in dieser folge nicht
fertig werde mit den häusern vielleicht
sogar gerade mal die sachen zusammen
kriegen aber das bauen geht an sich
relativ schnell eigentlich darf ich
innerhalb von fünf minuten glaube ich
werde in der nächsten folge twitter
kommentare einfach dann beantworten und
dann mal minecraft hier neue start und
hoffen dass es dann irgendwie weg ist
ich hab ich keinen plan woran es liegt
oder woran es liegen könnte diese länder
bugs die zahl das team keine handhabe
ich noch umgucken hier alles fit oder
hier in anderen regionen geht ja auch
alles führt wenn ich hier so einig dass
kaká naja muss ich jetzt mit leben
was kann ich eigentlich schon mal bau
und eigentlich 9 zunächst nicht mal eben
kurz die sachen zurück ist mir noch kurz
war ich zu treffen dabei das leben gar
nichts zu fressen mit willig so brauch
ich das bin nicht ich brauche nämlich
cobblestone und zwar drei stacks von
diesen teil
da ist kein cobblestone drin da stehe
das ist staunen da kann ich auch aus
dauern diese sachen bauen kann ich nicht
habe ich mir noch richtig gedacht das
ist auch staunt wie ich glaube ich ja so
viel story paar kumpels ton jungs ich
hab noch aber das ist gut
marvel ist auch immer toll das ist aber
man bekommt es dann mal bekommen habe
das grußwort place die braucht ursprungs
betreue ich auch ganz viele so er bei
nicht aber heuer gebäudes nicht ich
brauche ich auch nicht mehr die auch
nicht mehr so hier raus brauche ich
nichts mehr war etwas zu fressen so dass
jetzt schon wieder nacht das traurig und
wir sind schon bei zehn minuten
also ja meine lieben freunde die
kohlekraft potro
was wird die dennoch machen also bezogen
auf den krieg was jetzt erstmal alle
wissen wollen erst mal direkt regen dies
das beste
scheiß auf creek bezogen auf den regen
auf den regen auf den krieg ich werde
jetzt mal kurz pennen gehn
bezogen auf den krieg werde ich mich
anpassen was in den anderen städten
passiert
ihr seht immer noch hashtag ccp beste
partei bezogen auf den krieg werde ich
mich anpassen was in anderen städten
passiert
dementsprechend wenn in den anderen
städten krieg herrscht dann werden wir
uns selbstverständlich an diesem krieg
beteiligen
und dies selbstverständlich auch im
sinne des angriffe sondern ich im sinne
der verteidigung nur ist dann natürlich
wieder die sache wert an den krieg
anfängt dementsprechend fällt auch
daraus werden anfängt auf welcher seite
wir sind wir sind mich nicht auf der
seite der person die den krieg beginnen
das heißt wenn statt rote krieg beginnt
sind wir auf statt gelb seite wenn ich
könig werden das ist ja immer so die
sache wir haben sprit wird das geil und
zwar häufig von den brutplatz 863 auch
gut so da ist nix drin da ist kein
extrem effizient noch etwas drin zum
bauen
das freut nicht mehr glas brauche ich
auch nicht diese glasscheiben ich möchte
normales glas aber okay wir können
theoretisch
wir können auch glasscheiben nehmen das
ist relativ egal
und zwar
46 brauche ich davon ich habe jetzt drei
hallo server aluminium ohren da packe
ich doch erst mal drei todesopfer drin
denn das ist ok gil ich mir vielleicht
noch sein herz machen ja so freude sonst
würde ich sagen
oha wie viel hier schon nachgewachsen
ist das geil die cobblestone walls hab
ich fackeln brauche ich einen stack ja
die habe ich auch bruce wird brauche ich
drei stacks ich habe gerade mal 1 ich
brauche einfach so viel bäume ab wie es
geht hier weil ich so viel bei noch
brauche wie es geht deswegen ich wäre
das natürlich alles wäre nach pflanzen
das heißt wenn in einer stunde darauf
geht sind wahrscheinlich die ganze bäume
wieder nachgewachsen hoffe ich aber naja
so also das war auf jeden fall
hallo welche los hier
das war auf jeden fall auch den krieg
gezogen dass man es da anpassen werden
und wir sind auf der seite auf der wir
sind verbunden mit der stadt die
angegriffen wird ich denke wird statt
gelb wird angegriffen denke nicht dass
statt geld krieg anfängt sich mal so
grund vermuten ich hiermit meinen
königlichen eigenschaften um einen
königlichen adern kann das natürlich
selbstverständlich nachvollziehen
oder wenn wir angegriffen dann
angegriffen werde dann haben natürlich
kriegt mit den wir uns angreifen also
wenn du statt gelb angreift und stadt
roth hält sich raus dann sind wir gegen
statt gelb und immer wenn einer
sportstadt geld drauf ist wird
dementsprechend auch gekämpft da ich
jetzt auch zusatz herzen habe und ein
bisschen verzaubert bin werde ich dann
selbstverständlich auch in den krieg
ziehen und auch auf meinem chocobo die
erste partei bilden die dann in den
krieg ziehen wird und alle werden hinter
mir sein und hinter mir reiten sondern
rein das fällig nämlich auch richtig
geil dass solche gemeinschaftlichen
aktionen an geplant werden also alle
leute in der stadt blau dann irgendwie
auf den schoko breiten in den
sonnenuntergang und ein bisschen
quatschen über die situation der stadt
dies dass ananas solche sachen
solche sachen halt dafür werde ich mich
auf jeden fall einsetzen so wir brauchen
noch ein bisschen mehr als grußwort aber
ich setze auf jeden fall so viel nach
wie geht also ich hab so viele von
diesen komischen setzt legen wir da
nichts wächst
dann seid ihr auch nicht freunde so
jedoch ein bisschen was
doch der wäre jedoch eine rein da noch
ein und hilde braun euro da rein auch
domains freude und hier und da dann noch
welche wieder einen weg ja also das war
bezogen auf den krieg und auf
gemeinschaftliche aktionen
bezogen auf aufgabenverteilung kann ich
euch sagen dass der kongress partei
selbstverständlich alles sortiert ist ja
doch es sieht wirklich sehr viel
sortiert sein und zwar werde ich mich um
die essensausgabe kümmern und um die
königlichen aufgaben und ich fordere da
natürlich kein tribut bei der
essensausgabe ich fordere aktuell da
natürlich nichts nichts nichts keine
steuern
links ich werde dafür sorgen dass jeder
arbeit hat unter straßen gebaut werden
autobahnen sollen gebaut werden wir über
panzer fahren können damit wir den
vierten weltkrieg beginnen können der
dritte wird im echten leben fortgesetzt
der vierte ist dann in minecraft hero
selbstständig durch die kraft der total
sozialpolitische partei wir sind
natürlich links orientiert ich werde
jetzt hat die village irgendwie schief
gelaufen so wie viel braucht eigentlich
noch ganz kurz gucken als ich werde
natürlich gemeinschaftlich brauche ich
werde die wege verschönert ich werde
autobahn baut dahin
wir wollen natürlich nicht zum diktator
werden ich habe jetzt 34 stacks ich
brauche ich brauche drei stacks und habe
ich voll so ich habe aber da blablabla
so auch davon 86 und davon habe ich
jetzt 96 ja gut dann brauche ich noch
zwei specials von diesem goodwood also
ich brauche nicht zu viel von diesem
holz wie es geht
deswegen das ist eine reine abbau folge
deswegen hab ich mir gedacht das ganz
gut wenn ich einfach meine partei kurz
vorstellen die ihr immer noch wählen
könnte team einfach hashtag tcp unter
alle möglichen statt blau video schreibt
der beste partei weiter geht es im
programm
wat für wat steht noch die ccp ist
natürlich eine partei die sich mit den
einzelnen bürger
heftig das heißt wenn jemand probleme
hat von den zuschauern von mir von den
zuschauern von cadooz von vielleicht
auch kroos selbst vielleicht cave selbst
rechtsform bay
das ist zurzeit ein bisschen verhindert
wenn ihr seinen langen und schönen text
bei facebook gelesen habt dann könnt ihr
das eventuell auch nachvollziehen
ich hoffe dass er es nachvollziehen
könnt dass da einige zeit das mal keine
videos kommen deswegen sind wir zurzeit
in der stadt nur noch grund zum bay und
ich da kommen wir immer mit stadtroda
aufnimmt ist es sehr schwierig mit dem
aufziehen deswegen nur kämpfen die mehr
oder weniger unsere stadt fällt
auseinander und ich versuche da
natürlich die leute dazu zu bewegen mit
mir aufzunehmen bzw
in statt blau obdach zu suchen
also eventuell mal das wetter statt rot
oder statt geld bei uns übernachten oder
so einfach nur damit unsere stadt nicht
so leer ist
freunde ich will ja nicht dass unsere
stadt so eine geisterstadt addiert
können wir auch gleich stadt geist
nennen ich habe 46
aber ich glaube ich noch ein bisschen
mein inventar ist auch gleich schon
wieder voll
jedoch vorteile hin vorn beugen so da
sind noch viele bäume wären wir mit
mehreren ja was köche noch sagen wird
gab es bei den anderen königin noch bei
mir wird selbstverständlich über
entscheidungen wo ich sage ich weiß
nicht zum beispiel der eine will eine
riesigen blauen bahn die stadt setzt und
ich denke sohn eigentlich wäre es ganz
geil so blaue repräsentativ patriarchen
paneelen die verträge patriotisch
patriotisch ist das richtige adjektiv
ich glaube schon
dann bist du noch außen zeigen hey wir
sind stolz auf unsere stadt blau ist
natürlich ganz geil aber ist sondern ein
riesiger bagger statt wenn natürlich
jetzt auch nicht so schön für das
ambiente der stadt blablabla wenn das so
zwiespältige entscheidungen sind wo ich
jetzt nicht auch eine deutlich auf einen
nenner mit der person comedy das machen
möchte oder mit meiner meinung selbst
auf einen nenner komme dann geht
selbstverständlich die magische
miesmuschel entscheiden dementsprechend
wir die magische miesmuschel mehr oder
weniger hallo mein vize präsident meine
helfende hand in schwierigen situationen
mit ihrem studium als wirtschafts
michell kann ich selbstverständlich
sagen dass sie das hoffentlich und ich
denke auch sie wird es sehr schön
umsetzen so ich bin einfach mal noch so
ein bisschen doch bis mein komplettes
inventar als voll ist und dann ist auch
die folge spiel vorbei aber da haben wir
auf jeden fall schon mal fast alle
sachen gesammelt die wir brauchen wir
auch noch ein bisschen glas und die
sachen so ein bisschen um bearbeiten mit
der handys oder irgendwie sowas aber
sonst in zwei häuser können in der
nächsten folge logische motto damit ihr
mal sehen wie die zecke aussehen
ich werde jetzt noch so schnell wie
möglich machen damit ihr seht wieder die
stadt aussehen wird wenn ihr meine
partei wählt die hashtag tcp könnt ihr
noch fleißig in die kommentare schreiben
so viel ihr wollt weil wir einfach rum
specialty könnte nicht nur einen
kommentar schreiben können auf 1000
schreiben einfach oder 20 jeder der über
30 kommentare schreibt der ist auf jeden
fall treu gehilfe bei mir so ich fange
jetzt mal ganz kurz ich will dass in
etwa vorgestellt habe wenn man drei
minuten deswegen welches wahrscheinlich
gar nicht hinkriegen so habe ich dann
meine
wo ist denn hier habe ich denn bei
fashion show coupe du da kann ich jetzt
auch nicht hier machen hexer geistiger
so ich habe ganz kurz nach im ofen hier
aber ihr müsst ihr das nie
das ist schön da kommen das aluminium
brauchst du kannst du noch gern machen
so trockene noch mal so dann verbringt
jetzt letzten minuten damit hier ist ein
bisschen aluminium rauszukriegen das
aluminium natürlich ist auch ein
wertstoff der in der con kräften konnte
ich mich dass wiedereinsteiger die
kontraste partei verbreitet auf einen
sozialen netzwerken schreibt unter meine
facebook beschreibt es bei twitter
hashtag ccp schönste partei einfach
wunderschön für dich die wehr war das
nicht gedacht schon könnt ihr einfach
überall schreiben auch hier in die
kommentare natürlich hashtag ccp damit
die leute erfahren dass die legale
partei muss das jetzige geflogen
hö
die platte den weg
so
ja so ich habe deswegen der nächsten
folge werden wir wahrscheinlich noch ein
miniatur herz machen damit wir immer
mehr an die volle lebens anzahl an
kommen dann werde ich wahrscheinlich
gewählt hoffentlich hoffentlich von euch
hashtag city in die kommentare und ich
sagen sie uns in der nächsten folge
wieder wenn sie heißt minecraft hero
lasst mir wert oder und schreibt ccp die
kommentare und